in the middle of the earth in the land
of the Shire there's a brave little
hobbit that we all admire and his name
is Martin Freeman from Sherlock straight
up The Hobbit an unexpected journey for
those of you who know me and those of
you who don't I am an enormous Lord of
the Rings fan and The Hobbit an
unexpected journey is part 1 of 3 of the
trilogy that takes place before Lord of
the Rings it shows how Bilbo got the
ring and his whole adventure with
Gandalf and the dwarves - let's start
revealing this movie The Hobbit and
unexpected journeys directed by Peter
Jackson which is great he's the director
of the Lord of the Rings trilogy so if
ever there was a vision for The Hobbit
it's going to be this one and Bilbo is
played by Martin Freeman from Sherlock
in this movie and so Gandalf comes to
him he's like hey you want to go on an
adventure with me and go with these 13
Dwarfs to get their treasure back from a
big dragon and hobbits don't like that
kind of adventure so he's like no but
yeah sure we're gonna start out with
Martin Freeman is Bilbo Martin Freeman
owns it is Bilbo you watch this movie
you're like this is the only Bilbo
Baggins that I want to know you don't
even think about Ian's home I mean I
looked in Holland Lord of the Rings but
all I'm saying is Martin Freeman is
completely perfect he's likable he's fun
he's our underdog in this movie you know
cuz thorns like you I have no business
with us because I'm a really beefy
enormous dwarf who still you know small
cuz I'm a dwarf you're rooting for Bilbo
and Martin Freeman has great expert
delivering his lines and we have Ian
McKellen as Gandalf he's Gandalf the
Grey again we knew him as Gandalf the
white in the past two movies now we're
going half a century in the past so now
he's back to being the grey and he
completely kills it in this movie also
and I love it because you get more
screen time with Gandalf in any movie
that has more Gandalf screen time is a
good movie to me but that being said the
movie does take a little bit to get
going it's slow on the startup it starts
out kind of like that neighbor with the
really loud truck that you Hiram's
trying to start at 6:00 a.m. to get to
his job and you're like dude just just
get that thing going so you can get to
your destination kind of what this is
like half an hour into the movie I was
like we're still in the Shire and I'm
not even going to clown on the fact that
all the dwarves come in and they start
singing songs that actually impressed me
I liked the fact that they were singing
songs because the songs were in the book
and I was like wow accurate the lore I
like it so I get it that was really cool
to see but it starts out within home old
Bilbo talking about the whole adventure
with the dwarves
and their treasure and how it was stolen
what the elves did has a lot of
backstory it's like the beginning a
fellowship of the ring when you hear
Galadriel doing the voice-over and it's
a war with Sauron like that but you know
doors getting your stolen it's not
just the buildup in the very beginning
of the movie that takes a while to get
going there were a few scenes and
scenarios in the movie where I was like
that could have been shortened up a bit
don't get me wrong I know how build-up
works I know how scene setup works but
it's kind of like there's a time for
foreplay a time to move on it can get
drawn out for a little longer than it
should be drawn out but another thing I
did love about the movie were the
dwarves all right in Fellowship of the
Ring I don't mean to compare this movie
to the Lord of the Rings but people are
going to anyway kind of a misfortune of
this movie is going to be compared to
Lord of the Rings big time but if I'm
comparing characters you're stuck with
for the movies and fellowship with the
ring you just look at the crew and
you're like oh yeah they're completely
diverse and different you have humans
and dwarves and elves and hobbits this
one you're like oh I have dwarves and
one Hobbit and one wizard but their
personalities really shine not all of
them shine I mean there are some that
are just kind of in the background I
can't name off the personality types of
every dwarf in this movie but there are
a few that stand out luckily Thorin is
one of them Thorin is a complete badass
I wanted to like this dude in the movie
and I liked him every bit as much as I
wanted to
he's like the flagship of the dwarves
you got to make that guy badass you got
to make him and build those relationship
to you want to see them work it out and
become friends that's totally one of the
centerpieces of this movie and I loved
it but then there's the flipside of this
movie has a lot of CGI you can look at
Lord of the Rings and you see oh yeah it
has a lot of CGI in it but this one has
a lot more CGI was it bothersome it
takes away from the grid a little bit so
you're like us not as gritty as Lord of
the Rings is but also the Hobbit book
isn't as gritty as the Lord of the Rings
books are either so the fact that it's
not as dark as Lord of the Rings is just
accurate as less CGI than avatar I can
say that that's what that's saying much
you know and okay we got to talk about
this radagast the brown some people will
think he's alright
others will hate him others will loathe
him and there are some who will call him
that Jar Jar Binks of middle-earth you
won't get an argument from me if I have
to pick the weakest link in this movie
it's radagast the brown which is a
bummer because his story arc feeds into
something that's really cool with the
necromancer
so his character is relevant you just
wish they'd done them differently as all
I don't even know if how they did
radagast the brown in The Hobbit is
actually accurate to the lore cuz I
don't
that much about radagast the brown to
tell you the truth I know he's the lower
tier wizard so he's not going to have
that Gandalf persona or anything like
that that being said they need to make
him some weird gangly mushroom eating
hippie that looks like he's in this
movie to appease kids seriously he has
like bird on his head he's all
walking around like please make up what
are you doing darkness the Brown Wizard
of middle-earth ladies and gentlemen I
don't need all the Wizards to be like
cookie cutter confident old dudes but it
would have been cooler than radagast the
brown in this movie but for the radagast
haters in the world he's not in the
movie that much so he really doesn't
detract from the entire thing of this -
hour and 45 minutes saga he's in the
movie like 5 minutes but you will
remember the 5 minutes of screen time in
which you got the really old wizard meth
head of middle-earth and for people who
might say but it was accurate to lore
well then apparently I don't like
radagast in the book either I tried to
like him but in the end you think back
you're like but I don't however what
completely kicks ass the last two hours
of this movie completely kicks ass the
last two hours of this movie is
everything I wanted the Hobbit to be it
was awesome it was exciting Gandalf is
more badass in this movie than he's ever
been yeah the dude took on a Balrog of
Morgoth more badass in this Mel right
well Balrog of Morgoth pretty big deal
right so he's still badass in the Hobbit
and the riddles in the dark segment
that's a segment with Gollum and Bilbo I
could have watched that for three hours
and been completely entertained that was
a great scene in Gollum looks awesome I
mean the tech they used for Gollum is
now advanced ten years and he looks
picture-perfect like he's there and when
he's all like
I was like he's a little more than
pissed right now and it was great to see
just get emotion out of Gollum where
you're like yep
that's that steals the movie so this
movie's exciting it's really cool it is
a welcome return to middle-earth if
you're a Lord of the Rings fan you watch
it however if you're not a lord of the
Rings fan if Lord of the Rings didn't
win you over I don't know that this is
going to be the thing that wins you over
it's a great movie it's a good time I
want to watch it again the soundtrack is
fantastic there are definitely moments
in this movie where you're like this is
excellent its greatness this is
everything I love about Lord of the
Rings right here in front of me however
there are other scenes where you're like
that was kind of unnecessary and that
felt drawn-out and that felt a bit
forced like these scenes could have been
cut out and then put on the extended
edition you know which makes me wonder
were these
seems drawn out because they want to
draw out the entire saga to make it a
trilogy instead of two movies like it
was originally going to be I don't know
I can't qualify that probably in an
objective review I will say I would buy
the hobbit an unexpected journey on
blu-ray the movie did have its flaws but
in the end I had a blast with it it was
a welcome return to middle-earth and we
got to talk about the high frame rate if
you didn't know Peter Jackson filmed The
Hobbit movies in 48 frames a second
which is twice the frame rate as the
usual 24 frames a second which is what
movies are filmed in and how does it
look strange it's really crystal clear
you cannot argue that but there are some
scenes where you're like is that in
fast-forward it looks like the movies
playing in fast-forward but it's not it
just has more frames so it freaks your
brain out a little bit it takes about a
half an hour to get used to it so keep
that in mind I think it's gonna break
down like this if you work with film or
you work with frame rate and you
appreciate that kind of stuff you're
gonna find the high frame rate pretty
cool is it going to add to the
experience I don't know is it going to
take away possibly you're gonna find it
interesting nonetheless if you're the
rest of the normal populace of the world
you're going to be like this is
completely contradicting everything I've
ever known about movies in that I find
it kind of strange and I'm not sure I
like it so for your first viewing of The
Hobbit watch it in the normal 24 frames
a second your second time after you
taken in the content you're feeling
adventurous watch it in 48 frames a
second you should watch it in 48 frames
a second just to see because it's we're
seen it's a jump in technology that's
always fun right so The Hobbit and
unexpected journey have you seen it and
what did you think about it compared to
Lord of the Rings or standing on its own
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you